benvenuti in un nuovissimo oggi parliamo
di depilazione
in particolare delle ragazze quando si
depilano sono sicura che ognuno di voi
si ritroverà in almeno una di queste
tipologie e quindi buona visione ci
vediamo alla fine del video sono in alto
mare ma tu racconta di tutto ma stai
scherzando mi dici niente
sono troppo contento mi porrò maturava
comunque ha capito tranquilli che arriva
che da voi
passerete liscia
[Musica]
avevo detto io
[Applauso]
faccia
no
ma tutto qui
pensavo peggio marco ciao che sorpresa
una festa in piscina
certo che ci sono sì sì sì sì 15 minuti
non è perfetto va benissimo a dopo che
ci sia qualche parte dovranno pur
esserlo ma dove li si perfetta sono
pronto per la festa in cucina dove tu
così così così ho troppa paura e se
sbaglio qualcosa campo ma stai
scherzando non mia prima volta capito
cesta in ansia
guarda che facilissimo dalle strisce mi
aiuti a ma mi sa che non ci va dall
appuntamento con marco per quale motivo
scusa mi piace rom ai civili stato di
uscire si mamma sono che passa
cosa stai dice
guarda che doppie punte che ho ma se
volete ma guardare le doppie punte
sì ma anche 2000 peli effetti un po dei
piani di scegliere ma per questo c'è una
soluzione quindi adesso tu vai in bagno
di idee piriti trucchi ti fai belle poi
a quell'appuntamento fila sorrido 1 2 3
5 6 a posto allora adesso andiamo a
controllare che sicuramente sono rimasto
al pp lo piccolo e indifeso vedo niente
io tutti tutti incredibile novo beh fa
dono amo cosa sono questi peli
cioè tu pensi veramente di passarlo è
stato i pantaloni effettivamente sembra
un po un orso ma giusto un pochino
aspetto di qua allora facciamo così io
la faccio a te sulla fare a me messa che
chi è amica che sono allora vai
ok dimmi quando ci sei mai 1 23 ago
eccoci purtroppo arrivati alla fine del
video come al solito fatemi sapere
lasciandomi un commentino qui sotto a
quale di queste tipologie appartenete
con l'asta corrispondente per esempio a
star la tattica hashtag la multi tasking
eccetera eccetera
se volete acquistare le strisce
depilatorie che utilizzato nel video vi
lascio qui sotto in descrizione il link
allo store di amazon
se questa è la prima volta che vedete un
mio video ricordatevi di iscrivervi
subito al mio canale e di cliccare la
campanella che trovate vicino al tasso
di iscrizione per rimanere sempre
aggiornati su tutti i nuovi video e
soprattutto per essere i primi a
commentare e soprattutto seguitemi su
tutti gli altri social facebook
instagram e musicali io vi mando un
bacione ci vediamo al prossimo video
adoro ciao
[Musica]